as heavy combat between Russia and
Ukraine continues in eastern Ukraine
supplies on both sides are running low
so far in the war countries around the
world have been involved in providing
equipment the red on this map shows the
Nations that have pledged weapons to
support its Kiev and the blues shows the
countries that have assisted Moscow
according to Western intelligence aid
for Ukraine has been widely publicized
while Russia's deals have been largely
shrouded in secrecy satellite images
on-the-ground footage and Customs
documents analyzed by The Wall Street
Journal tell us more about the nation's
supporting Russia's War Machine
[Music]
North Korea is one nation that has been
supplying weapons to Russian Fighters
according to the Biden Administration
U.S intelligence said the mercenary
Falls of Wagner has received infantry
rockets and missiles from the country
the White House released satellite
images that it said shows five Russian
rail cars participating in the weapons
transfer in a return trip from Hassan in
Russia to tumangang in North Korea this
image also shows a nearby open-air
storage unit which military analysts
said facilitated the delivery in
response to the US in November North
Korea denied supplying weapons to Russia
and said it had no plans to do so
Russia's Embassy in Washington didn't
respond to a request for comment
deliveries of ammunition are crucial for
Russia to continue its intensive
fighting as the war largely becomes one
of attrition but in a sign that stocks
are running low Russia has launched
fewer shells in recent weeks than last
year military analysts estimates that
moscow's forces are now firing 10 000
shells a day down from twenty thousand
to thirty thousand last summer that's
still well above Ukraine which fires an
estimated 3 000 a day and is also
struggling with low stockpiles
Russia is also receiving supports from
Iran Ukrainian officials say Moscow has
used hundreds of Iranian drones to hear
civilian and Military targets Iran has
acknowledged publicly that it has
supplied drones to Russia
military analysts say drones consistent
with Iranian self-destructive unmanned
aerial Vehicles can be seen in these
videos of strikes in Kiev
Moscow and Tehran are also moving to
build a new Factory in Russia that could
make at least six thousand Iranian
designed drones in the coming years
drone attacks have been a key tactic
used by both Russia and Ukraine in the
war
Ukraine's military has posted videos
like this one that it said shows strikes
on Russian targets using turkish-made
drones
and then there's China both the US and
China say Beijing hasn't provided
weapons to Russia but Russian Customs
records provided to the Wall Street
Journal in February by the center for
advanced defense studies a
washington-based non-profit show that
China has indirectly supported moscow's
War efforts
the records show that Chinese
state-owned companies provided Russian
government-owned defense firms with
navigation equipment jamming technology
and jet fighter Parts Russia's Embassy
in Washington didn't respond to a
request for comment
a month later Chinese leader Xi Jinping
traveled to Moscow for a multi-day
summit deepening economic ties between
the two Nations
U.S officials say China is also
considering supplying artillery and
drones to Russia China has denied it as
considering such action and has in turn
pointed a finger at the U.S and its
allies for fueling the conflicts by
providing Ukraine with weapons
Russia is gathering its forces as it
attempts to break Ukrainian defenses
across the Eastern dunesque region
looking to its allies could help Moscow
as Kiev begins to receive a large cache
of western-made heavy weapons
as the war continues outside
Partnerships can prove to be vital as
both Russia and Ukraine prepare for
fighting to intensify in the coming
weeks
so this